ANYMORE.
BECAUSE THAT LEVEL WAS SO GOOD.
THEY DON'T TALK ABOUT ANYMORE,
SEAN.
THE REASON THEY DON'T TALK ABOUT
IT, THERE IS NOTHING TO TALK
ABOUT.
SPENT THE REASON, THE NEXT THING
YOU SAY THOUGH, I THINK, MAKES
YOUR POINT.
YOU SAY AS YOU SAW YESTERDAY,
THE WHOLE NONSENSE ENDED WITH A
POOR PERFORMANCE BY A MAN NAMED
ROBERT MUELLER, INCOMPETENT
PERFORMANCE BUT THEY SAY A LOT
OF IT STARTED WITH UKRAINE.
WHATEVER YOU DO, IT IS
IMPORTANT.
>> President Trump: AND IT
DID, IT ENDED WITH A POOR
PERFORMANCE AND THIS IS AFTER
TWO YEARS OF AN INVESTIGATION
WHETHER $45 MILLION OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT, THEY HAD 2,500
SUBPOENAS, 500 WITNESSES, ALL
BECAUSE PROBABLY HILLARY CLINTON
SAID JUST LIKE SHE DID WITH
TULSI GABBARD, JUST LIKE SHE DID
WITH JILL STEIN, SHE SAID "JILL
STEIN IS A RUSSIAN ASSET.
NOW COME I DON'T KNOW JILL
STEIN.
I KNOW A ENVIRONMENTALIST AND
PROBABLY A GOOD WOMAN BUT THE
LESSON SHE HAS A RUSSIAN ASSET.
I DON'T KNOW TULSI GABBARD BUT I
KNOW WHEN THINK SHE IS NOT AN
ASSET OF RUSSIA.
THESE PEOPLE ARE SICK.
THERE WAS SOMETHING WRONG WITH
THEM.
>> Sean: I WANT TO SHOW YOU
THIS AND WE WILL PUT IT UP ON
THE SCREEN FOR PEOPLE AT HOME.
UKRAINIAN EFFORTS TO SABOTAGE
TRUMP BACKFIRE.
THIS WAS JANUARY 11, 2017.
YOU WERE INAUGURATED.
THIS ARTICLE TALKS ABOUT HOW
UKRAINE WORKED WITH HILLARY TO
INFLUENCE THE ELECTIONS.
THEY GIVE CHAPTER AND VERSE HOW
THEY DID IT.
NOW, AS THE PRESIDENT, DO YOU
FEEL THERE WAS -- YOU SPENT TWO
AND HALF YEARS WITH RUSSIAN
COLLUSION AND IGNORE THE DOSSIER
IN UKRAINE ADMITTING THAT THEY
HELPED HILLARY.
>> President Trump: THE
DOSSIER WAS A DISGRACE.
THE DOSSIER WAS TOTALLY FAKE.
NOW IT HAS BEEN PROVEN TO BE
FAKE.
PEOPLE, YOU KNOW HOW THAT WAS
DONE.
YOU HAVE A TRACK RECORD NOW AND
YOU KNOW AS WELL AS EVERYBODY
THEY ARE DOING AN INVESTIGATION,
BUT I THINK BEFORE YOU DO THE
INVESTIGATION, SO THEY DO A FAKE
DOSSIER ON ME.
THEY TRIED TO RELEASE IT BEFORE
THE ELECTION TO AFFECT THE
ELECTION.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY DID.
IT'S THE ONLY THING I RESPECT
ABOUT THE PROCESS IS THEY
REFUSED TO PUT IT IN BEFORE THE
ELECTION BECAUSE IT COULD HAVE
HAD A LITTLE IMPACT.
MAYBE IT COULD HAVE HAD A LITTLE
MORE THAN THE IMPACT.
THEY DO A FAKE DOSSIER THAT WAS
PROBABLY MEANT TO GET OUT BEFORE
THE ELECTION SO THAT THEY COULD
AFFECT THE ELECTIONS.
AND LOOK AT THE PEOPLE THAT
WROTE IT.
LOOK AT WHERE THEY CAME FROM.
AND LOOK AT THE WIFE OF THE MAN
WHO WORKS, I WON'T EVEN MENTION
NAMES, AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.